hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to be answering
your property investment questions i've
been in property now
for 12 years buying houses selling
houses developing properties and i'm
going to be answering all of your
niggling annoying questions around
property tax
rent to rents lease option agreements
how to buy properties with very little
money
and a host of other things now last week
there were so many questions on youtube
so i'm gonna answer last week's
questions
but as i'm answering last week's
questions if a question
pops into your brain i want you to
comment below in the comments section
and then next week on sunday at 7 00 p.m
i'm gonna answer
your property investment questions now
please do
smash the like button and also you need
to subscribe because if you don't
subscribe and turn the notification bell
on
you might ask a question and i might
answer your question next week on sunday
but you never knew i answered your
question because you weren't subscribed
and you didn't have the notification
bell turned on so do that now
smash the like button and let's see what
we've got so
jordan guy from last week says hi samuel
is there a way to buy a second house
with a 10
deposit now the answer to that jordan is
if you're buying a house and you want to
put down a 10 deposit
traditionally that's going to have to be
a residential mortgage which means
you're going to be living in the
property
now it is possible to get a second home
which is also a residential mortgage a
lot of people get a second residential
home
and you could put down potentially 10
the only problem is
i get the feeling that you're looking to
buy a second home as an investment now
if you're looking to buy a second term
as an investment
generally speaking the banks are going
to want to lend you a maximum of 75
possibly 80 but normally 75 which needs
means that you're going to need to put
in
about 25 as a deposit now of course
you can do creative financial strategies
which is what i
often share on youtube but generally
speaking second home or investment home
as a buy to let you're going to need 25
deposit
hope that helps what else do we have
kevin james says can you legally live in
your own
rent to rent and or lease option
agreement property
and the answer to that is yes you can if
you
live in a lease option agreement that's
effectively like
rent to own and if it's a rent to rent i
know a lot of people that do this
they'll rent a property off of a
landlord but then they will
re-rent the rooms in the in the in the
house now as long as you do this with
the correct
contract and the correct management
agreement this is perfectly okay
next ben says i have just set up my deal
sourcing company and
i'm in the process of becoming compliant
good for you that's really good to hear
i've done quite a bit of training and
i'm looking to focus on bmv
brr properties as a starting point i'm
curious to get your thoughts on selling
a first deal
and attracting investors to you with
little experience or sales
what would you suggest the best method
of connecting and attracting investors
is
especially in the current climate thanks
ben so first thing i want to say ben is
in the current climate it is not
difficult
to package and sell deals there's a lot
of investors that are looking
actively to invest in property right now
in fact people are getting gazumped at
the moment which means
an investor will put forward an offer
and then another investor will outbid
them so
it's not a bad time to package and sell
deals in terms of
how would you go about doing your first
deal always ask
what they want so rather than
frantically looking you said you were
looking for a brr deal or a
below market value deal rather than just
frank frantic looking for good deals
you want to speak to investors first and
say hey what are you looking for and in
business
it's always about finding a problem
bringing a solution so
find an investor who's got a problem i.e
he can't
find a house he hasn't got the time he
hasn't got the knowledge find out what
that investor's looking for
go and find it and then just give it to
him that's what deal packaging and deal
selling is
i hope that helps if not comment some
more questions but thanks so much for
that one
by the way if you enjoyed this video by
the way guys please do smash the like
button it really helps me make sure the
blue thumb is pointing up it needs to be
blue uh greg greg says
i'm going to do service accommodation i
like that i like the fact you just said
i'm going
to do service accommodation there's not
like i'm thinking about or i'm going to
try i'm going to do it
so no doubt you're going to be
successful how can i find out the area i
like to choose is right
and i'll have enough customers each
month okay so greg in terms of
demand what i would recommend if you're
looking for service accommodation
is to look at what hotels are doing in
the area go on booking.com and see if
the rooms are full see how much they're
charging
also go on airbnb and on airbnb it's
really cool because you can literally
look at the calendars
of other properties that might be
similar to the one that you're thinking
again
and you can see not only the price but
also how full they are how
booked that property is so that will
give you a real good idea of the
demand in the area for that kind of
property i hope that helps thanks so
much for your question
scott mcclory hi samuel looking to first
time
buy and rent a room out while living
there
do i need a buy to let mortgage or is a
residential mortgage fine
also is this an okay strategy to use to
get your foot in the door of property
investing love the videos thank you
so um scotch good news is you do not
need a buy to let mortgage to rent a
room at in a house that you're living in
a residential mortgage is absolutely
fine you do not need any permission
you do not need planning you don't need
a license and you don't even need to pay
tax how awesome is that you can you can
um rent
a room out or multiple rooms out in your
house as long as it's not above 7 000
pounds
it is completely tax free fantastic rule
so yeah that's good news for you scott
go kick some ass let me know what
what happens ian taylor i am 77.
wow i've got to answer your question if
you're 77 i love how we have like
17 year olds and 77 year olds on the
channel
i have just got a mortgage at 3.35 by
applying through a limited company the
mortgage company wasn't interested in me
they were only interested in the
property i wanted to remortgage okay
there doesn't seem to be a question in
there
but ian that's great news i'm really
glad to hear that you got a good rate
i'm glad that they weren't too
interested in you and you don't want
them to be too interested in you really
you want them to be interested in the
property
and the great point that ian raises here
is that buy to let
mortgages the lenders care more about
the property than they care about you
so when when you're trying to get a
mortgage to live in a house they're
going to ask you all kinds of questions
they're going to say hey
you know how old are you and where do
you currently live and what do you earn
and
what's this and what's that and what are
you spending a month and what's your
partner spending a month from there's
all these questions
but when you're doing a buy to let
mortgage they're still questions but
they're more concerned about the house
so as long as you get good at finding
good
houses good investment houses they just
need to make sure that they know that
they're going to get paid
from the tenant that lives in the house
they want to make sure that the house
stacks up so
really really cool all right next joseph
how do you sell a deal to an investor
without them stealing the deal and
cutting you out the picture
very simple joseph you use an nda
contract a non-disclosure agreement a
confidentiality agreement
and you do not give them the details
until they sign that agreement
wasteman noob okay fair enough
please explain your experience of when
an investor pretended to know about a
property you found them
yes okay so i might have mentioned this
in a previous video
very linked to the last question
actually so if i
do not if you do not have an nda let's
say you find a property and you think
this is a really good property and you
like it
and then you want to sell it to an
investor the investor when you tell them
about the property
they might try and cut you out of the
deal and and
and just do it do the dirty on you now
what i've had
is i've had it where investors because
they don't want to
cut me out of the deal and do the dirty
on me because it looks really bad and
they'll be embarrassed
and their reputation will go down the
pan i've had some investors that have
said to me
oh oh it's 32 church street oh my
goodness
that's so crazy because i actually
already knew about that property
and i'm thinking no you didn't
and they're like yeah i literally found
it on my computer yesterday and i was
about to view it i was gonna ring up
that's so crazy ah
in other words i'm not gonna pay your
fee now because i already knew about the
house
normally and it's so annoying when this
happens because it's like
i know you're lying and you know that i
know that you're lying
but you can't prove it so bottom line is
just have a have an agreement in place
that just says lot
i'm going to give you this um i'm going
to give you the details of this property
but please can you confirm that if i
give you the details of the property
and you um go ahead with the deal you
need to pay me my fee if i say i already
knew about it then why are you trying to
pay me in the first place for a property
when you already knew about it so
it's really important that your
confidentiality agreement is really
airtight
and it stops people doing the dirty on
you when you're a deal packager hope
that
helps what else do we have afro
promotions
hey samuel very important question here
i want to get an loa this year very soon
i want to make it as cost effective as
possible regarding the solicitor
if i just get one to represent the
seller is that okay
or do you recommend i get one to
represent me as well i don't want to if
it's not necessary also a follow-up
question
if the house i'm getting under an loi
lease option agreement
costs 80 000 pounds how how much can i
roughly expect to pay out for legals etc
assuming the house isn't in need of
renovation would appreciate if you can
help thanks so afro promotions firstly
the fee
for a lease option agreement isn't
really going to change depending on the
size of the house if it's an 80 000
pound house or if it's an
hundred thousand pound house you're
gonna typically pay around about
eight nine hundred pounds plus vat to
get a solicitor to draw up a lease
option agreement now
in terms of whether you need the seller
and you the investor or the buyer
to have an independent solicitor you
don't need to
the seller needs to be represented so if
you're doing a lease option agreement
the seller should always have a
solicitor
representing them lest they try and say
oh i signed under duress
in five years time when the house has
gone up in value and you try you're
trying to exercise your option to buy it
should you have a solicitor you don't
need one i
i often don't use the solicitor because
i know the crack
but if it's your very first time it
probably would be worth paying the
thousand pounds or whatever it is to
have a solicitor to represent you so
it's recommended but it's not
legal legally essential hope that helps
all right next sam hawkins
hi samuel if you decide to use land
registry to contact a landlord directly
how would you explain to them how you
found their details without scaring them
off
so sam hawkins if you're finding a
property address from land registry
normally you're going to find a property
that you've got a particular interest in
so
let's say it's empty and you drive past
it every day
maybe it's like i don't know got like a
fire burn and it's been neglected and
the weeds are great and you just think
that's got real opportunity and you find
out on land registry who owns it and you
pay three pounds and you then write to
the person or speak to that person
i don't think it's creepy at all i think
it's like hey this house is neglected
it's empty
i've seen the weeds i drive past it
every day i'm really curious would you
be would you be interested in
taking an offer on the property i'd like
to buy it that's not freaky
so it would be freaky if you were
contacting like people that were living
in the house
but if normally when you when you set
when you find someone on land registry
it's because the house is neglected you
don't know who owns it
i wouldn't be sending letters to
everybody that owns the house and
hunting people down the line registry
anyway
so it kind of depends hope that gives
some context let's see what else we have
matthew says hi samuel big fan how much
does it cost to start up a service
accommodation unit
also do you recommend paying a deal
saucer on the first unit
so how much does it cost it really
varies to get a service to accommodation
unit you might have to pay for furniture
you might have to pay a deposit or some
upfront rent to the landlord i mean
normally if you've got about two three
four thousand pounds
that should be ample to get you your
first service accommodation deal of
course it really does depend
should you pay a deal sorcerer i would
say no because
you don't want to pay someone to do
something
when you could do it yourself and i find
that with deal sources and
rent to rents and stuff it's all a
little bit i've seen so many people get
burned i've seen it go wrong so many
times the only time i would recommend
paying a deal saucer to find you a deal
is if you know how to find the deal
yourself
so they can't pull the wall over your
eyes you know it but you haven't got the
time
but if you don't know how to do it
yourself don't pay them because they
could
really really stitch you up and there's
so many people out there that are
selling deals
and they're not actually that great and
they're just pulling the wool over your
eyes
relying on your un knowledge that's not
even a word relying on your lack of
knowledge a lack of education
and they'll make the figures look great
on paper and it will go bad and they
charge a fortune so
be really careful i've seen it go wrong
too many times
i'd rather invest a deal saucer will
charge you about three four five
thousand pounds
on average for a nice rent to rent
property why not just invest that money
into yourself
get the knowledge get yourself a deal
and then you've got the knowledge to do
it again again and again and again
that's what i would recommend doing and
that's not just because i run training
courses that's genuinely
the best thing to do so what else do we
have um
abdullah samuel how do i convince my dad
to take me to the crash course because
i'm too young
he isn't taking me seriously samuel
please help
it's like i can't even get him to check
the dates
please help um okay i do that what i'll
probably say
firstly respect congratulations for
trying to get your dad to come
and i would just have the conversation
with him i just say look dad
this is really important to me i
most what do you want me to do dad what
do you want me to do in my life he'll
probably say i want you to go to
university and
get a good job okay cool and i'm very
open to that dad
and if i go to university and get a good
job the reason i want to do that is
because i want to make good money would
you agree yeah great so
there's this program out there that's
teaching how to make money through
property how to be an investor
i'm really interested in this please
it's free
what do i need to do to get you to come
along with me
and honestly i think most dads would do
it or just say oh just try a different
technique rather than trying to sell it
maybe just say
look she's really important to me you
know i love you dad and
i really want you to come along what do
i need to do to convince you
i mean if he doesn't come after that
then stuff in go find another dad no i'm
just i'm just kidding
then just ask your uncle or ask your mom
or
you know find somebody else and then
when you become really successful in
property what's going to probably happen
is he's going to be like
oh i always believed in you you know
certainly that's always what happens but
anyway i hope that helps good luck i'll
see you there okay
um hey jazz hello samuel i have a
property worth around 170
000 pounds with around 120 000
refinancing potential
i'm looking to invest into hmos and
making my full-time job
i.e means of living and quitting my
full-time job
also is there a path of at least
resistance for refinancing
and lastly which hmm management firm do
you recommend as i've heard some horror
stories
hope to be on winners wednesday one day
so
two questions there i hope to see you on
winners wednesday one day as well that'd
be awesome
um firstly you're talking about
refinancing what's the best way to do
that who are the best lenders
i would say get a good mortgage broker
you need to speak to an independent
mortgage broker that has
access to all of the different lending
criteria and they'll be able to find you
the best
mortgage suitable in terms of hmm
management company
it varies because you want to there's i
can't recommend you a hm management
company because i don't know where you
are
so you need to find one that's in the
area that you're looking so i would
suggest going on spare room
code at uk looking at all the rooms
available
in the area that you're in and then
you'll be able to see all the agents
and just call them and say hey are you a
hmm management company in the area and
just talk to them so
there are some horror stories there
always are when things are done badly
but that would be my advice i hope that
helps good luck let me know if you need
any help and look forward to seeing your
success and your more questions
okay aaron holmes we'll just do maybe
one or two more after this and then i'm
gonna wrap up i hope you're enjoying the
video please don't forget to comment
your questions as well don't be passive
about this
because honestly i believe that most
people that aren't succeeding in the way
that they want to
it's because they haven't got the
information because they don't ask for
help so i'm here
it's free it's youtube comment below and
i really am going to answer your
questions i'm going to do my very best
at least
to answer your question next week sunday
7pm don't forget to subscribe let's see
what else we've got aaron holmes
hello my name's aaron hello um i'm from
suny leeds i'm 30
and i own two rental properties with my
third going through at the moment
i've got two by the way congratulations
that's awesome three houses
is fantastic for 30 years old i've got
two zero percent interest cards before
christmas 12k
and 6k limit i use these cars instead of
the money i own from work
i have the money i would have spent day
to day in stock market worth about 21
000 pounds at the moment
but the problem is my credit rating is
really poor now as i've maxed them out
would you just pay them off or half
off or fourth rental property fourth
rental property
that's the like listen i'm not a
financial advisor i don't know all the
internet of your situation i'm not sure
what you're doing in the stock market
right now but
what i would say is firstly your credit
should not be poor because you've maxed
out on your credit cards because
if you're paying back the interest which
you should be able to because if you use
the credit cards
to max out to buy houses hopefully those
houses are
renting out and you should be using the
rent to pay back the interest
plus be left over with some more which
you're saving up for your fourth
property awesome
so you shouldn't be getting bad credit
for that the only reason you get bad
credit is when you
don't pay on time that will give you bad
credit i'd be trying to build your
portfolio
i just i just keep building it and and
keep kee continue getting that debt and
if you've got zero percent interest
on your credit cards i mean geez what i
would watch is
how long is it zero percent if it's
gonna suddenly go up to
like fifteen or twenty percent you need
to be mindful of that you need to have a
plan
to make sure that you can either switch
it over to another credit card or pay it
off normally with these zero percent
credit cards
they lure you in they say oh it's zero
percent for 20 months and then after 20
months they charge you an absolute
fortune but you can normally transfer it
over to another credit card and just
keep doing that
you know every couple years so i don't
know but i'd keep growing your portfolio
scholar one more after this comment
yours in below i'll be answering next
week
scholar says hi samuel thanks for your
helpful videos please please please
answer my question here i am answering
your question i hope you're watching
though
i currently live in a property i own i
have a two year fixed term which will
end april 2021
i would like to turn this property into
a buy to let once the fixed term ends
and sell it to my limited
company okay yeah i really wouldn't
wouldn't do that
i would simultaneously simultaneously
like to buy a new property to live in
i wouldn't do that either i need to do
this before the stamp duty holiday ends
in order to save on stamp duty
i wouldn't worry about that either does
this sound feasible
um i'll finish your question i don't
want to terminate my fixed term before
it officially ends as the fee is seven
thousand pounds however the stamp duty
holiday ends in march 21
and my fixed term ends in april 21 is it
possible to do this without penalty
please help
listen i really i'm really not on the
same page as you right now shola i love
you
and i think it's great that you're
watching these videos and i think it's
great that you're taking action
but you've got a property right now and
you're saying
you want to turn that property into a
buy to let property
okay that's probably not a good thing to
do you probably better have to sell it
and then
go and buy a buy to sell properties
better but then you're saying you want
to sell it
instead of just getting a buy to let
mortgage on it you want to sell it
to your company but then you're going to
get hit with stamp duty
but but then you see him on in the next
breath to be really bothered about stamp
duty because you're rushing to buy
your own house i'm really
i don't know i mean it sounds to you
know what you should do and i hate to
sell but you should join and honestly
folks
it's a pound okay it's a pound one pound
that's my unashamed plug
i would join samuel 365 on samuel
365.com
costs one pound you have a seven day
trial and then thereafter you can cancel
any time there's no cancellation charges
and it's 95 pound a month
when you're a samuel 365 member cost one
pound you can book a mentoring call now
this might not be with me it could be
with me
or it could be one of my mentors and you
that's what you need to do and you need
to just bounce off
and work out a strategy uh you'll also
as a member of samuel 365 get coaching
calls with me every week
and you'll also get um the crash course
and lots of other training which is
gonna really really help you out in this
time so show that that's what i would
recommend doing
and sorry for the unashamed plug but
that's what you need
okay good luck one last one jonesy
jonesy bruce hi samuel i have a 180 000
mortgage on a 250 000 pound house with
wife and kids
is there a way i can get into buy to let
housing as a passive income
with little savings thanks in advance
for sure you can
jonesy you can get into property with
little savings but if you've got money
it's easy if you've not got money it's
hard
if you've got money you can just buy
houses if you've not got money you need
to do things like raise money you need
to do joint ventures you need
events you need to do lease option
agreements you need to do
bridging finance and buy a property and
push the value up and get
development finance and then refinance
like it becomes more complicated
so can anyone get into property with
very little money
yes will everybody know why
because it takes effort and you you've
got you've got to be a property investor
but also if you've not got much money
you need to be a property entrepreneur a
property investor is someone that puts
money into investments
cool but if you want to do that and
you've got no money then you need to be
a property entrepreneur
and a property entrepreneur is someone
who finds ways to make money and is
creative and raises money so
be a property entrepreneur be a property
investor together row it like run
a boat with two wars become very wealthy
become very successful and then contact
me
and uh tell me what happened because
your success is my oxygen thanks so much
for watching this video guys i hope you
enjoyed it
look forward to seeing your questions in
the comment box below please do smash
the like button it really helps me out
and also
subscribe because i love it when you
actually get to see my videos so turn
the notification bell on
i'll see you next time peace out
[Music]
you